[Music]
hi Eddie so high-level feed the father
[Music]
now I'm asking you do you understand
about eternity I want to know where the
author is the idea of the Trinity is it
mentioned do you know the story of
Abraham that's a manifestation of the
Trinity okay but this is not clear can
you see it's ambiguous
it doesn't say of you will be will be
clear anything for you if you don't want
to believe everything will be unclear -
yes but why why why you always fixated
in the issues of the Bible they the so
called issues that don't really exist in
the Bible they don't you don't look in
the Quran so many issues is tournament
I'm trying to understand to sanity yeah
you're trying to refuse the Houston okay
but secret the truth you should trust
you three yeah yeah okay so let's stop
let's not accuse one another of
something we don't know because I don't
know what's inside of your heart just
like you don't know what's inside of my
heart maybe maybe after tomorrow I will
be the biggest and better Christian than
you and maybe maybe three or four days
from now you'll be a Muslim I don't know
but you know you don't know like we
don't know this yeah anyways the point
I'm saying is subscribe thank you God
knows the heart what I'm saying to my
friend is this for us right I'm saying
as someone who looks at the Old
Testament yeah the Old Testament which
the first five books of which is sent to
Moses the rest of which are sent to
other prophets when I look at these
books I'm trying to find the message of
the Trinity which then came afterwards
in the form of the Nicene Creed and 325
that Constantinople in 381 you know the
calcium created for 51 these three
treats I believe formulated Christianity
yeah
now your ideal of theology and belief in
God is shape my belief is is shaped by
these Creed's not the Bible and not what
the prophets have said now if I want
something very clear just like in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter son
assumption okay I'm doing it's an
assumption
maybe all right but I believe it's a
justified assumption what I'm going to
say to you is this in the book of
Deuteronomy chapter number 6 verse
number 4 it says Shama is trying Adam I
know you know Adam I had the here o
Israel you Lord
no it's finite yes but even Jesus
confirmed is one goal from them now if
you're saying that God is one and the
Old Testament is very very clear that
Shem is trying Adonai Adonai the one
quotation is Deuteronomy chapter number
6 verse number 4 okay where it says this
is called the Shama everyone should know
this is very well known yes this is
Shama Shama is right with hear o Israel
yes here therefore always be absurd to
do it but it might be increase Mike Lee
and the Lord God of their fathers
optimize deal no no Deuteronomy chapter
6 determine chapter 6 verse 4 best
merciful hear o Israel the Lord God is
one God
of course why he can be one because he's
got muscle mighty nobody don't discuss
your right I understand you have a point
that basically saying if God is powerful
he can do whatever he pleases to us okay
but now what that makes it seem like is
what you're saying is for God to be this
like me going through a king than saying
if you are the most powerful why don't
you come here and be a dustbin man I'll
show me your power so if he says no
not us are you are not powerful what
we're doing is we're using the concept
of power in the wrong way because we're
seen if you're the power then if I said
okay can go to become a goat the concept
of almighty but is that know him and I
know him here I'm here
if I sit you can God become I was a bit
la my friends you know can tell what
become my truth
this is okay so you have to define what
he can but he don't want good wicked
that's perfect but he said that no no no
when I'm working in London he's good
very good you made it really for some
point you said he can but would he is
that mr. Obama if I said Obama why don't
you join the British the American troops
and fight who say I don't want to I can
buy the luncheon now the question is
that he wanted to became nice okay okay
one second now now you made a very valid
point so the question that we need to
ask is how could you come to us and say
that God wanted to become a man where is
your evidence that God wanted to become
a man because you said he can but would
he choose to if he can't become a shoe
or a goat or an elephant why did he
choose to become a man just the way you
said can God become my shoe you said he
can but would he - and that's the same
way look my shoe at least my shoe
doesn't go toilets at least my shoe
doesn't have to eat that at least but
when you say God became a man I have to
think to myself stop okay if you become
a man you have to eat when you eat you
have to go toilet so I say to myself God
is all-powerful going to the toilet you
know my teammate my heart says that
doesn't make sense to me
this concept of God becoming human where
do we where do we find out where do we
hear that girl becoming human yet in the
Bible yeah if the Bible is not the Word
of God
would that make you reflect and say okay
if it's if is because we only get it
from the Bible the Bible is also see if
we can show you that the Bible is not
the Word of God can you still say and
rely on the scripture we believe by
faith that this is the world unless
reason I'm saying you're getting the
scripture like God being human the time
for you since from the Bible yeah yes it
is Jesus Christ died for your sin okay
if this is this information is in the
Bible yeah yes if I prove to you
brothers that the Bible is not the Word
of what what does that mean for you as a
person
I don't believe you can prove if I do if
I do what does that mean for you I could
prove that the Quran is I will leave
this time if you do right now I'll leave
this time if you show to me the Quran
has errors if it's been changed I'm
telling you what would you do if you -
if I show to you the Bible is not the
Word of God what would you guys do well
if you prove me that I mean you cannot
do anything right if it happens okay now
not even if you kill me I will still
believe is true
if you pulled me I will still believe
it's true good the answer good perfect
you know what you've done you know what
you've done I said to you if you show to
me in the Koran there's areas of
contradictions I am ready to question
and leave the fold of Islam why because
if I put my faith into it I'll see even
if you said to me look it says here the
Quran is from Satan I'll say no I don't
care my faith is strong you can't win
with me
I'm reasoning with you if you're true
and sincere which I'm sure you guys are
if I showed you the Scriptures corrupted
you your heart needs to say hold on a
second I need to question everything
about the scripture I'm ready to do that
why is it that when I ask you you're
saying even if you show me then how you
seeking the truth if I'm if I'm saying
okay this is what it is without so
what's different between you in the
Hindu yeah what's difference between me
and you they have faith they have us
believe in many in many ways we have
faith in Jesus Christ and I believe in
Jesus because I have faith but what
about reasoning if somebody came to you
and said this is change this is somebody
some man wrote this are you still gonna
say I have faith that's blind faith okay
what's five plus five five plus five
yeah it's ten no I'm gonna be 12 I have
faith it could be 12 because in a
difference sister knows of counting it
could be equal to be 12 it could know
how and you don't know you don't know
that I mean I mean well yeah we can use
all logic you need to understand also
that God it is Almighty the same rules
who works in our logic does not work for
this no no but the same rules rule you
so then you can just be a Hindu do know
why why are you actually look God decide
to reveal himself to the scriptures yeah
Shiva Shiva and so you can believe in
anything it's all about faith no no
rationality yeah its rationality
okay let's use rational back over
rationality is faith
none of our online fake your right faith
I'm not blind so if you believe you're
right we need that's what I asked you
yeah
okay if you talk about blind faith yeah
then you stop should stop attacking the
deity of Jesus Christ I start to go
blind figures wait blind faith is to
believe in the you know dynamic blind
faith Brian away from leaving something
with that reasoning I think around you
know for example Mohammed yeah himself
it was much inferior of Jesus Christ
when we come to power he couldn't
perform anything but this doesn't make
it look there was other process you have
other miracles I don't see this one is
better than the other because you just
can't believe I do I'm God I agree our
light is well say to me you're my friend
I want you guys to know that I'm not
coming aggressively yeah I'm gonna say
to you generally either is the real yes
I want to do this yeah I want to say to
this my friend if you're saying we
cannot agree upon rationally sorry yes
if you're saying we cannot agree upon
rationality as a way to decide between
right things and wrong things which is
what you do in school which is what you
do our work which is what you do
everywhere else but when it comes to the
Bible you don't want to do it for some
reason if you agree that the Bible is
only a faith thing and that we can't use
rationality then I can't continue this
conversation why because that means to
me that you don't want to try and find
the truth you just want to punch on the
religion of your father and for me I
cannot discuss with you our day when
everything is not rational because it's
also know
no no of course we believe in the
supernatural what we're seeing is that
there should be some Universal
understanding of God yeah we should all
say you know what we all agree on is the
most powerful we all agree
he's the all knowing we all agree he's
the most wise we all agree there should
be a universal understand I'm not saying
I want to know exactly how God works of
course not God can do miracles but if we
went if I stopped to an atheist and I
said if there was an hi in intelligence
he would it be all-powerful like yes I
don't believe but you should be very
strong I'm like okay it should it be oh
no he'll be like okay if he's the
Creator you should know it all so this
is something that universally we would
all agree on what you're seeing is faith
look we have faith as well we say hey I
don't believe I have a family I've seen
good okay but once it was it wasn't
that's objective I can say to you this
lamb changed my life you say to me
Christian you change my life Buddhist
would say I change my life this is
subjective experience we can't use that
as an evidence I can't say it's time as
the truth why I became a better person I
you can see what we're trying to see is
happy I'm reasoning if you have only
faith that means cross the road don't
look left to right close your eyes but
you have to have faith that you won't
get hit by a car and you also look left
right you see I'm trying to say so what
we're trying to say is here that have
faith but also have reasoning when you
cross the road you're not going to say I
have full faith I'm gonna go no of
course you're gonna have faith under
left right
you
thank you me one thanks Arnie subscribe